irving with a head of steam
fender shot good kyrie irving gets the
scoring started green
puts it up knocked away by allen
into the hands of irving thought about
it he's got a mismatch
irving soft touch it goes for three
he put it over bruce brown to get some
early offense then kyrie irving for
three
brown is sturdy 6-4 202.
irving turns the corner so you're saying
we're going to be saying that
quite a bit just get used to it former x
irving oh it goes
kyrie irving has been perfect from the
field
the block by prince he got bogdanovic
irving turns on the jets for two
and the nets have come out smoking hot
and what does that lead to kyrie irving
with a sweet finish on the starting five
has been
fantastic 20 to five lead that foul was
on irving
kyrie irving oh he can't miss
kyrie irving bottom
i mean kyrie kyrie irving has got so
many moves and tricks across the board
there has been a sustained level
of energy and that's what's been most
impactful
irving another kyrie irving is
locked in in every single aspect
and you can't replace them but you need
to find ways to help shore the gap
kyrie irving it's stuck on automatic
and then in triple threat the rip
through the shot
separation brown was a high school
football standout you could see that
with his physique
irving splits defenders for two
the patience and then kyrie irving right
through
what are you gonna do go bare play